[Applause]
is the new chief of japan's governing
liberal democratic party
he's also set to become prime minister
as his party and coalition partner
control the houses of parliament
it's the second time the former foreign
minister has run for the leadership
after competing against outgoing premier
yoshihide sugar last year
in his acceptance speech kishida
promised to lead the party to success in
next month's general election
i want to firmly show a reborn liberal
democratic party to the japanese
citizens and urge them to support us
from today i will
with all my energy get straight to work
party members around the country and
members of parliament please work with
me
a first-round vote had failed to produce
a majority winner and two female
contenders dropped out of the race in a
runoff kishida faced taro kono an
outspoken minister in charge of japan's
covet 19 vaccine rollout who'd been
ahead in opinion polls
but widely regarded as a safe pair of
hands kishida had the support of
lawmakers and beat his rival by 257
votes to 170.
analysts say kishida's rise to the
premiership is unlikely to affect
defense and international relations
he supports close ties with western
democracies to counter china's growing
influence in the region on the economy
kishida has pledged to spend big on a
stimulus package and emphasized the need
to distribute more wealth to households
but first he faces a difficult challenge
a general election that has to be held
by november
what i expect to see
is something ambitious like a
very large stimulus package
dedicated
to
pandemic management and the health
system in general
although of course
nothing is really going to be
implemented there's going to be no
evidence of success in time for the
election so in allah to a large extent
kishida is going to be selling hope and
asking the electorate to trust him
rather than demonstrating any concrete
results there
kishida may be seen as a stable choice
but some analysts say his bland image
may work against him in the upcoming
polls florence louis al jazeera